as we speak.
And it may already have happened.
By the time you listen to today's show, the
House of Representatives is debating in advance
of voting and they may have already voted
by the time you listen to this about the second
impeachment of Donald Trump.
Now, you all know if you watched the Monday's
show and or the Tuesday show, that I believe
impeachment should not be a political calculation,
but rather a responsibility, a duty that the
House of Representatives has questioned.
One very simple flowchart.
Did the president do something worthy of impeachment?
If the answer is yes, then you impeach.
There are no other considerations because
it is such an important responsibility placed
on Congress.
What is very interesting is that this will
not be merely a partizan impeachment in the
House.
We are hearing from more and more Republicans
that they are indeed going to vote to impeach.
They may already have.
Depends on when you listen to this.
Congressman John CatCo from New York was the
first Republican to say publicly he will vote
to impeach Donald Trump over his role in inciting
a violent mob to storm the Capitol.
Last week.
He said he will join Democrats today when
they vote to impeach Trump for willfully inciting
violence against the government of the United
States.
We then heard from Liz Cheney from Wyoming,
Republican congresswoman and daughter of former
Republican Vice President Dick Cheney.
She will vote to impeach today.
Then we heard from Republican Congressman
Adam Kinzinger that he will vote to impeach,
saying that it can what Trump did essentially
cannot be ignored, period.
And this is starting to get very, very interesting.
We also heard from Republican Congressman
Fred Upton that he will vote to impeach Donald
Trump, and that puts the number of Republicans
that will be voting to impeach Trump at more
than zero.
And that's what matters.
Now, ultimately, we will get the full number.
We I don't yet know what it is as of this
moment.
The vote is likely happening or minutes from
taking place.
But ultimately, the real questions are going
to be in the Senate.
And we are going to talk about that in a little
bit.
I don't I don't want to get ahead of myself,
but there is going to be a real question as
to whether any Republicans would be willing
to vote to convict in the Senate.
And we will get to that.
Now, how much praise do these Republicans
deserve in the House for voting to impeach?
Very little.
That's that's the reality.
The dominoes are falling and that's good.
Republicans are starting to jump ship.
Many of them.
Many are not, but many are.
And to me, this mostly is opportunistic individuals
trying to save themselves.
That being said, I still say keep them coming.
I still think, again, people should just vote
based on what happened.
What happened is Donald Trump behaved in an
impeachable manner and thus any vote to impeach
is the correct vote and that should be welcomed.
But it's a lot easier to be the second person
to take a stand.
And second applies in a number of ways here.
This is the second impeachment of Donald Trump.
We have already seen some Republicans like
Mitt Romney and others distance from Donald
Trump.
And it's always easier when your participation
is going to get less and less attention and
the second person to jump on board gets less
attention than the first and the tenth gets
less attention than the second.
And that's the way it goes.
And ultimately, many of these.
Republicans are realizing there's simply nothing
to gain and everything to lose from continuing
to side with a seditious president.
I hate to be so cynical about this, but this
is Republicans doing exactly what we predict,
that they're just doing it like a week sooner
than we expected.
And what I mean by that is there was every
indication for over a year, certainly for
months.
And you've heard me talk about it every indication
that once Trump is gone, the Republican Party,
both those who supported Trump and those who
supported him publicly but not privately,
and those who started to distance from Trump
publicly at a relatively earlier stage, this
was always the plan.
The plan was always when Trump is gone to
do a sort of on steroids version of what they
did with George W. Bush.
Remember, George W. Bush did not campaign
with John McCain in 2008.
George W. Bush was unpopular and Republicans
made the calculation.
It probably hurts John McCain to have George
W. Bush on the campaign trail.
This is like a steroids version of that where
you are going to see tons of Republicans go
into pretending Trump.
I barely even remember that and I certainly
wasn't with it.
And going back to all of the things the Republican
Party has pretended to care about for a very
long time, we've got to reduce the debt and
the deficit, religious freedom, lower taxes,
cut business regulation, get in the way of
so-called government takeovers by Democrats.
And sometime maybe they'll call them communists
and socialists, et cetera, et cetera.
So this is not a surprise at all.
It's simply happening a week to two weeks
before Trump leaves office.
We were more leaning in the direction that
it would happen.
Once Trump is actually gone.
That's it.
And they deserve no praise.
They don't deserve to have their reputations
rehabilitated.
But to the extent that it's correct for them
to vote to impeach, I'm with it.
And after the break, we are going to talk
about what's happening in the Senate, including
multiple reports that Mitch McConnell is pleased
with Donald Trump being impeached a second
time.
But what does that mean when Mitch McConnell
says that the devil is certainly in the details?
So we'll have more after the break.
And also on our Instagram, which you can find
at David Pakman, The David Pakman Show at
David Pakman Dotcom.